you know what i'm saying but it's just
different ways to skin a cat who the
[ __ ] says
where does skinny cat come from that's
kind of crazy to say i've never skinned
a cat yeah skinny cat do you know anyone
who's skinned a cat oh i think it'll be
a hard [ __ ] task too i my cats are
crazy you know that's what they're
[ __ ] distressed what yeah i always
say i'll [ __ ] i'll take a fight with
a dog over a [ __ ] tomcat it depends
it depends on the type of dog though
because dogs get busy okay like a golden
lab give me the golden uh airbud you
wanna fight airbus i fought air i'll
fight airbo airbud over [ __ ] jerry
bro where's it tom tom
dude cats are [ __ ] they're quick
they're ninjas and they got the claws
bruh i um
i named my cat frank ocean do you have a
cat
would you consider yourself a cat person
i hate his ass
but we just got like a mufasa thing it's
like two lions like but he be
doing [ __ ] like this is my my shorty cat
so okay they gonna be yeah get on the
tallest part of the
whatever yeah yeah they collide with
someone just stand there like you just
at the top of pride rock like he's
overlooking the peasants yeah like this
is my just so y'all know this is my [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that so okay different but
the cat's name is
frank ocean yeah do you have a dog as
well
had a dog
um
passed away oh that's rough man i'm a
huge dog person turtle named
where turtles live
they're supposed to live kinda
so this is
we went to a fair or some [ __ ] and got a
small little turtles you know when they
give it that's kind of corner main too
yes oh yeah you got it anywhere you're
going and they're selling animals on the
side of the street
they're just giving these [ __ ] out
it's like they're like we can't get
these off these joints are sick take the
turtle gave us this one turtle
we keep the turtle for a couple weeks
feeding them and all of this stuff but i
started doing research and they say
these turtles need a companion or they
will
just off themselves so in the next
couple of weeks
[ __ ] stop eating
he started making a little turtle noise
and then he started putting his head
under the you know you got the little
gravel at the bottom of the tank this
[ __ ] was in pure loneliness like he
committed suicide it was the saddest
i've seen turtle suicide it was the
saddest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
i'm talking about in the span of like
three days four days he was just like
i'm done he just killed himself he's
like i'm not eating where's my girl
where's my where's anything i just need
to knock around some stuff side note if
the cats frank ocean who's the turtle
his name was turtle they're just turtle
yeah i respect that i don't feel like i
don't feel like yeah amphibian right
are turtles amphibians am i right there
what the [ __ ] is it it's a what
a reptile what the [ __ ] is an amphibian
in a lizard a frog is an amphibian okay
okay turtles reptiles
they don't hear i don't feel like they i
feel like they only see like heat when i
was a kid i had a
box turtle and i named him fat joe
that's hard
i'd be knowing my [ __ ] you know